for those who see this as national
liberation for those who see the EU was
a sovereignty sapping monster this is
their moment 11 p.m. GMT on January 31st
2020 Britain is no longer part of the
European Union and a load of children
moaning about it think that the European
Union had a lot at fault and had there
been a bit more accommodating to David
Cameron this Boris Johnson who staked
his political career on brexit and won
the prime ministership has marked it
with an address to the nation when look
at the potential of this country waiting
to be unleashed I know that we can turn
this opportunity into a stunning success
and whatever the bumps in the road ahead
I know that we will succeed
we've obeyed the will of the people
we've taken back the tools of
self-government
never before has the EU had to do this
it hopes it never will have to again
experienced only an expansion now the EU
has taken down a members flag because
it's left Europe's leaders want to show
that there's little to be gained from
this we want to have the best possible
relationship with the United Kingdom but
it will never be as good as membership
for Europe and for those who voted
remain this is a moment of sadness and
in a sign of the constitutional
challenges ahead for the UK brexit is
boosting the calls in Scotland for
independence it's very it's very very
sad and I think what it really does
though is it shows that there isn't
really a future but in Europe and the
way that we've enjoyed over the last 34
years and but there's a future for
Scotland and Europe but for the crowds
in Parliament Square on Friday night's
the possible breakup of the UK is near
doom mongering considered do mongering
to their concerns that Britain should be
too fussed about doing a deal with the
European Union at all
[Music]
and this is their moment this is their
night
it doesn't disguise the fact though that
the heavy-lifting sorting out a new
trade relationship with the European
Union is just beginning that countdown
clock to brexit has just finished where
the countdown to the end of the
transition period in little under a
year's time well that's just begun Rory
challenged al-jazeera London